Since the dawn of man,
meat has been on the menu.
A pure beef hamburger.
♪ Chick-Fil-A ♪
Over a pound of meat.
We have the meat.
And even with growing trends
of vegetarian diets and
plant-based substitutes,
around 89% of the world population
consider themselves omnivores.
We have come a long way
from our hunter and gatherer roots.
We have managed to
establish a whole industry
designed to feed almost
7.7 billion people.
We've maximized production
and we've managed to reduce hunger
over the past couple of decades.
And although we've become
exceedingly efficient
at putting meat on the table,
raising livestock animals by the billions
comes with its own set of consequences.
If animal agriculture
continues to expand the way it has
there's a risk that we won't
be able to stop climate change.
But with rapid advances in technology,
we might soon see a food industry
that leaves all those problems behind.
I'm about to be
one of the world's first
commercial customers
for lab grown meat, cultured meat.
To Eat Just is the company
and I'm very, very excited.
Here is the chicken.
Looks pretty crispy outside.
It's really good.
I mean look it's really tasty.
Here at 1880 in Singapore,
cultured chicken is being served
under a regulatory approval
granted by the Singaporean government.
It's the very first time
a cultured meat product,
meat made from animal cells grown in a lab
has been approved for commercial sale.
Eat Just, the company behind
these chicken nugget style dishes
is based out of San Francisco
and got their start in 2011
developing plant-based egg substitutes,
like mung bean scrambled
eggs and mayonnaise.
But it wasn't until 2017
that they announced
they were shifting focus
to a cultured meat product.
In order to feed the world that we live in
a lot animal protein,
we need to take a third today
and it'll be more tomorrow
of our world
and make it dedicated to
feeding chickens and cows.
We go to areas that are filled
with biodiverse rainforests,
taking a bulldozer to them
and planting soy and corn
to feed the chickens that we eat.
Climate change is accelerated
by the kind of animal
production that we engage in.
When we bring animals
in tiny little spaces,
it accelerates the probability
that more zoonotic diseases
are gonna impact our families.
And from a morality perspective,
why do we need to cause any
harm to any other living thing
to have dinner that tastes good?
It does not have to be that way.
And those things underlie
the force of this idea.
The meat alternatives
that have made it to the market thus far
have been plant-based,
imitation beef and pork
made from ingredients like
pea protein and coconut oil
by companies like Beyond
Meat and Impossible Foods.
That's a very different
proposition from cultured meat,
which is made from actual animal cells.
I'm a huge fan of any
company, of any person,
trying to make a product that's
improving the food system,
including all the plant-based proteins.
Maybe in some future menu,
you'll have this kind
of cultivated chicken
and you'll also have
a plant-based version.
That's fine.
But I guess you have to ask
yourself in our lifetime
is that diner likely to also
remove the conventional option
on the menu too?
We do think we need a
more permanent solution.
We do think we sort of need, if you will,
an end game to this problem.
And we just think this is more likely
to be the path to achieve that.
So animal cell technology
has been around for several decades
for applications such as
development of vaccines
and other biotherapeutics.
The first known prototype
of cultured meats
was done by Mark Post earlier in 2011.
And essentially he was
developing a beef patty.
It was a very expensive prototype.
If I'm not mistaken above
250,000 Euros at the time
to produce just one beef patty.
It was more of a proof of concept
to really demonstrate that
this technology is possible
and that it can be done.
The way that we grow and
produce cultured chicken
is essentially we isolate chicken cells
from the chickens without
having to kill them,
so from a small biopsy, for instance.
We immerse these cells in a liquid broth
that contains the nutrients
that the cells need to survive
and be healthy and to grow.
We really need these cells to multiply,
to reach the numbers that are sufficient
to make a meat product.
We're looking into the cells
that are really important for meat.
So we think about muscle cells, fat cells.
By that isolation,
we are able to form those
muscle tissues in culture.
The culture happens inside
of a fermentation tank,
what we call the bioreactor,
which is essentially providing
the same conditions as the animal body,
warm temperatures, some sort
of mechanical stimulation,
so that the cells are exposed
to very similar conditions
that they have inside of the animal.
After the cells proliferate
and reach a certain density,
the final step is essentially
to separate those cells
from the liquid broth that they are in.
We just make sure that the product
meets our quality and safety standards,
and then those cells are
ready for consumption.
Milk, cheese, yogurt,
a lot of those derived from fermentations.
The only difference is
that they are starting
from a different cell type.
In this case, we're just
using the animal cells
as the initial and
beginning of the product.
Eat Just has developed
chicken nuggets so far
with far more textured chicken breasts
planned for the future.
But another cell-based
meat startup Memphis Meats,
has already started working
on culturing other animal cells as well.
We've done beef,
we've done duck,
we've done chicken.
And these are things that are favorites
in various parts of the world.
For instance, people in America
love beef and chicken.
People in China love duck.
So we wanted to show
that we at Memphis Meats
can produce meats that
we as a global population
love to eat.
There's a lot of similarity
in how we grow the meats
from various animals or fish,
but they're also different
because of nutrients they need
and how they actually come together
to form the final product, the meat.
And I think it's very similar
to how we also grow various animals.
There's similarities in the feed
that we give cows and pigs and chickens,
but there's also
differences how we cultivate
and it's very similar for us as well.
So we've been working
with the FDA and the USDA
for the last three years
at really developing the guidelines
on how this food should be regulated
when we come to the market.
As soon as we get regulatory
approval in the United States
people that will be able
to go to their supermarket
and buy it and enjoy it,
they'll be able to go to
a restaurant near them
and order meat directly from animal cells.
But it's not just getting the meat right.
Once approved, the gates open
to a very high potential demand
and scaling becomes the next big hurdle.
Before we could only make
chicken for myself, my friends,
my girlfriend, my family, my colleagues.
Now we actually have the ability
to make chicken for millions of people.
So that allows us to invest
and to allow the economies
of scale to drop the price.
The second is we need to reduce the cost
of the nutrients that
these cells are consuming.
So I think chicken feed
raises or drops the price of chicken.
The nutrients we feed
ourselves does the same thing.
So we need to drive that down.
The cell density is
another technical element.
We need to continue to increase that.
And hammering all those things
over the course of the
next five, 10, 15 years
will put us in a place
where we're significantly below the cost
of this animal protein
and that will be one of
the main inflection points
that will lead to a
new way of eating meat.
So here is a closeup of a
half-eaten crispy chicken bite.
You know what?
What I'm really thinking
is just I'm eating chicken.
I like chicken.
You know, the normal chickens eat,
I don't know where they came from.
And so I don't know why
I should be very stressed
where this came from either.
The meat market is worth
more than one trillion dollars annually.
And there are over 60 startups
in the cultured meat field.
Cultured meat has attracted
several prominent investors,
including Sergey Brin, Richard
Branson, and Bill Gates.
What is also interesting
is that even meat giants,
such as Cargill and Tyson
have invested in the space.
It's this disruptive
potential of the market
as well as the promise to greatly
reduce the climate
impact of meat production
that has attracted investors.
It remains to be seen
who will get regulatory
approval in which countries
and whether consumers
will like lab grown meat
enough to make the switch.
And while there's no evidence
that lab grown meat
is any less healthy than traditional meat,
there's an ongoing debate
over how healthy eating
meat is in general.
But if these products are a success
they could be the
beginning of a more humane,
less destructive meat industry.
The food and ag industry
is the most innovative
industry in the world.
It's always figured out how
to feed a growing population
and we've never failed doing so.
And it's been very clear to
us that we are part of that
and we're gonna figure out
how to feed the next three
billion people joining us
and I just see an evolution.
We can do this a bit differently.
We can do this in a way that is consistent
with the kind of people
that we want to be,
the kind of planet that
we all want to live in.
We can build a food system
that reflects really the best
characteristics of who we are
and that makes me really hopeful.